it's great to welcome Jason Murphy back
to the program he's an anti-poverty
activist and an assistant professor of
philosophy at Elms College in Western
Massachusetts
he serves on the National Committee of
the u.s. basic income guarantee Network
and is also a media outreach organizer
for the basic income earth Network Jason
it's so great to have you back I think a
good place to start would be from the
last time you've been on what has
happened with some of the basic income
experiments that have been done notably
Finland is going to be wrapping up their
experiment we talked about that on the
program earlier in the week how in
general would you say these experiments
have been going well they've been very
very interesting as a generator of news
and discussion on basic income there's
one in the works in Ontario I was one in
the works in Barcelona the finish one
generated a surprising amount of
attention there was a wave of news that
declared incorrectly that Finland had
implemented basic income and some
newspapers described the program one way
and some described another and of course
it's actually not true a few thousand
people in Finland received a guaranteed
income if they went and got a job they
would still have it and the government
was mainly only interested in it as a
social science experiment and they're
ending it on schedule the sociological
or economic research wing of the
governments called Kela Kela they're
going to be studying the data they've
issued no findings but you'll find a
tremendous amount of opinion columns and
even what looks like a news article
declaring Oh Finland has rejected it and
they just plain heaven yeah and one of
the things Jason I found interesting was
that there was sort of some ambiguity in
the reporting a lot of the reporting
around that as we discussed on the
program earlier in the week said that
there were people who were displeased
with the idea that you didn't even have
to be looking forward
in order to receive the 560 euros that
were sort of part of this test scenario
and some of that was misreported as sort
of like a finding of the of the test
right and it's sort of like my thought
was yeah the entire point of ubi is that
there is no means-testing there's no
sort of like required activity for it
that's what the test is and the
criticism that it's a disincentive to
look for work is not a specific
criticism to the Finnish test that's
like a criticism of unemployment or of
ubi and other social welfare insurance
that is beyond the scope of this
particular program so I think the
reporting was very confusing on it oh
yeah well essentially you're right so if
someone's displeased they're displeased
with the idea basic income we're
receiving we're communicating with a lot
more people a lot more interest in basic
income since we last spoke the people
just know the effect basic income would
have on work but the government in
Finland is not my kind of government
that's a austerity rather conservative
government they were hoping and they're
looking into see that basic income would
be an incentive to look to work because
no one's worried about losing their
funding so all they replaced in their
experiment was unemployment benefits so
it was just not it was just not a early
version of a basic income regime that's
gonna require an ethical commitment we
have to make a decision that we want to
wipe out poverty and we see how to do it
basic income is definitely one of the
strongest proposals out there and the
United States it's about there would be
about four percent maybe five of the
gross domestic product and everyone is
above the official poverty line and then
we can look around and see what else we
need to do but that's not something
where we need this immense amount of
social scientific data if your town
could see an increase
income why would you say oh no no let's
go experiment on a few hundred people
first no you do the thing that raises
your average income well to play devil's
advocate I mean one of the arguments
that's made and it's a very similar
argument that's a that's made against
increases to the minimum wage if you
subscribe to supply-side economics is
that if everybody gets call it eight
thousand dollars it doesn't matter the
amount eight thousand dollars for the
year or ten thousand or six thousand
whatever whatever it is if everybody
gets that then all prices and costs
associated with living will just sort of
be upwardly adjusted by roughly those
same six eight or ten thousand dollars
per year and in the net it's not
actually going to improve quality of
life it'll just cause inflation how do
we fight against that talking point well
now there we have data like so pretty
number crunchy economist so business
professors say the kind of stuff you're
talking about you know conservative
opinion columnist they'll say that the
devil's advocate thing you're bringing
in here but economists do not fear
increases an average income so what
happens if you have cash that you can do
whatever you want with you can look
around for better deals some people are
spending more on groceries because they
live in an area that has only one
grocery store with a little bit of money
that's yours you can get to the next
grocery store that's just one example it
would work the same with pharmacy things
like that so a lot of people are gonna
get better prices because they can use
some resources to go get the better
prices also I mean there may be some
increase in pricing it would be weird
they would defy conventional economics
but also most rebellious economics it
would defy them if say twelve thousand
dollars a year as a basic income ended
up cost
everybody that much sure yeah right the
exact numbers of course may not shake
out that way I mean I guess the example
that is sometimes pointed to his
Switzerland right Switzerland has a very
high standard of living and even jobs
that in in the United States would be
minimum wage or barely minimum wage earn
a significantly higher we would call it
sort of a living wage and people point
to it's really really expensive to live
in Switzerland I sort of experienced
this firsthand visiting the country a
few times there is certainly sticker
shock there that's sort of the example
that people will point to which is hey
we kind of know what happens when the
average income is significantly higher
things cost what they cost in
Switzerland and everyone's happier and
they live longer
that's very true right people seem
pretty happy with the set up in
Switzerland don't they I mean and but so
I think that's sure I mean there may
well be the case that some of these
things happen again we're gonna have
more options so there may be may have an
easier time moving somewhere or housings
cheaper if we don't need both people to
hold on to that job without a crisis we
may be surprised by some of the effects
of basic income but it's going to come
as a product of choices we make with
assets we now have right this is like
we're distributing assets and not just
entitlements minimum wage increases have
not typically had these massive
increases in essentials like prices and
rent and things like that correct we get
data there we have state lines or
there's different minimum wages on both
sides so you know there may be some
effect but raising minimum wage to you
know $15 an hour movement is really
gonna deliver just a better standard of
living for the least well-off but for
the least well-off that are employed do
you think Jason that a lot of what we're
seeing in terms of the opposition is
more ideological
because the idea of a non means-tested
program that gives money to people is
actually not that unusual when you look
at the details right like in Alaska it's
widely known that there's this fund that
distributes money to residents based on
the money that comes in through oil and
gas returns right drilling in the in the
state etc you get that just for living
there and people don't some of the same
people who say that something like
universal basic income encourages
laziness don't really ever say anything
about that program in Alaska which we
already have here in the United States
so is it really the idea of this that's
a problem we also need a movement we
need to push for seeing basic income as
something that fights poverty which in
Alaska no one has really pushed to make
it do that it was implemented by a
governor who did what Tobias poverty but
he had to really fight to get any of it
in at all and it's typically been
something of an afterthought nobody has
said wow we could really build this
thing so it could have a long time ago
then much bigger in Alaska it is proof
that it's doable the idea that well if
when I first started working on basic
income I was surprised how many people
thought it must be impossible and I
would have to just point to Alaska to
prove you can do any of it the new
question now because people can they've
heard enough about it right I'm not the
first person bringing it up people have
heard enough about it
where they know it's probably doable
we're wondering what the consequences
might be
how much do I really exploit the
insecurities of other people and I've
had nominal lefty types saying well
who's gonna clean up the building right
and these are folks who will tell you
how liberal and left they are but
suddenly they're worried
that they're gonna have to pay a little
more to get people to do things because
they're not worried about starving
anymore
that's incredible and given especially
how much more wealthy we are than we
used to be we have more to share than
we've ever ever had it doesn't seem that
way like if you're viewing and you're
thinking no way
it's because it's not getting shared
there's more to share it's not good
share
so it's just kind of incredible that we
would think of still using desperation
right let's write of eviction or not
being able to pay for medicine
I want everybody who works around me to
oh I want the job to be something that
makes sense to them works in their plan
and it doesn't have to be utopian we
just need a little bit there so that
between jobs people are gonna be ok and
again it's four to five percent of the
GDP being looks like it would secure
twelve thousand a year for everyone
let's pause the conversation there were
speaking with Jason Murphy about
universal basic income we will pick it
up with him tomorrow much more to
discuss
we're continuing our conversation with
Jason Murphy who is an anti-poverty
activist assistant professor of
philosophy at Elms College in western
Massachusetts serves on the National
Committee of the u.s. basic income
guarantee network he's also a media
outreach organizer for the basic income
Earth Network so Jason next thing I want
to talk about is something I've
discussed on the program before which is
that we want to responsibly advocate for
programs like universal basic income and
in being responsible it's important to
take into account that people like Mark
Zuckerberg and Jeff Bezos of Amazon and
Bill Gates and many many tech
billionaires really seem to like the
idea of ubi
and that doesn't mean that they like it
necessarily four motives of self
enrichment but when there's something
that a lot of tech billionaires like the
idea of it's good to think about why
that is so has that trend for you made
you cautious about really thinking
through how such a program would work
what do you make of the tech
billionaires that seem to love it well
it's been interesting
so us basic income guarantee Network I
was getting together before Silicon
Valley started talking about it in the
way that we've seen quite a bit the last
couple years so it's been a clash of
cultures in some ways why are they
backing it I think it's important to
note that the majority of Silicon Valley
wealthy are not backing it we're doing a
lot from them but the 1% are not
rallying around basic income we'd have
it if they were so why are some looking
into it maybe it's because they want to
look smart maybe it's because they
actually do depend on a market this is a
way of expanding markets that they're
good at tending to so in the same way
that Ford Henry Ford needed higher waged
workers
to be able to sell cars it's very likely
that a basic income could create the
kind of consumers that the figures you
name Zuckerberg etc might be able to
sell too well the Amazon one is I think
you're making a very good point with
because when you consider like a hundred
million people or something are Amazon
Prime subscribers which means that for
the hundred bucks a year they get free
two-day shipping on whatever they want
from Amazon if all of a sudden you have
an extra eight ten or twelve thousand
dollars in your pocket and those aren't
eight ten or twelve thousand dollars
that you need in order to merely eat or
have a place to live it does stand to
reason that a significant portion of
that might go into buying stuff on
Amazon and getting it shipped for free
in two days to your house right oh sure
and the one percent can only buy so many
whatever it is we're doing on Amazon
which can be things like razors and you
know socks and jerk so there is a point
where the 90% really start to matter
more to some of the figures we name I
think some of the actual proposals that
are written down there's some detail we
got a look at those because some of the
ones coming out of Silicon Valley are
really different from other ones coming
out so some of them are very libertarian
in nature they only want to dismantle
current support and then there's an idea
that whatever money we save by
dismantling whether it's SSI food stamps
etc and just put it into a basic income
that would be a bad deal that's
overestimating the amount of support
that's out there and when you only need
four to five percent of the GDP to
that's what the numbers look like to
guarantee twelve thousand a year for
everyone it seems to me very silly to
have to cut all this others support in
order to fund it but that's not what
we're seeing with some of them if I can
just to do the few things I want to
touch on here and we're starting to get
a little bit tight on time there are
those who are suggesting something like
a job guarantee program as an
alternative to ubi
or more commonly a negative income tax
which would be a progressive tax and
thus only apply to individuals making
you know below a certain amount and the
idea is that the money would be better
spent rather than just giving a set
amount to everybody even though that's
bureaucratically simple that the
stimulative effect would be greater if
the money was applied where it is most
needed
do you believe number one that the that
these are interchangeable ideas and
number two what do you think the
negatives would be of looking at
something like negative income tax
versus a flat ubi well I'm I'm excited
to see more people considering programs
that guarantee everybody access to an
asset that includes the job guarantee
the idea that the government would see
itself as an employer of last resort and
we're seeing people back there so that's
exciting a negative income tax would get
to people it would be a guarantee if
suddenly I have no income as long as I
can get somewhere quickly right if I
quit my job because it's horrible right
my job is good if someone quits their
job because of injustice in the
workplace I want I want them to not I
want them to be able to live until they
get the next job so as long as that
that's not to me that's not bureaucracy
that's kind of one of the things I'm
hopeful about basic income with there's
versions of negative income tax that
would do that again a lot of it has to
do with the details how many people how
high does the income have to be before
it cuts off if you're progressively
funding a basic income the 1% is going
to be paying more in than they get out
so mathematically it can be very similar
to negative income tax so again I'll
read the the details I like Andrew
Yang's proposal I like this Hughes's I
like I would love to see a tax on
pollution traffic
financial transactions things like that
so that we can tamp down things that are
hurting us and help people that need it
I really want people to know they have
it that they have this income as an
asset to me that's worth any other
problems but again if you count the net
costs a lot of descriptions of how much
basic income cause go with the total
cost the gross cost the net costs it's
three to four percent I needed to get
everyone twelve thousand what about the
argument that's made about negative
income tax that it would be easier to
make up a reality politically on the
basis that you don't need to create
anything new you simply adjust tax rates
which is done you know every four eight
or however many years every however many
years we have political decisions made
around that and that it would be simpler
to implement with the infrastructure we
have do you think that that's a good
argument in favor of a negative income
tax but a basic income is the similar
infrastructure it can be done just as
well on the 1040 form we just have the
grant right there you know here's the
amount you get and then the 1040 form
calculates what we charge in tax it can
be done through Social Security as well
we already have the infrastructure for
basic income with both negative income
tax and basic income and job guarantee
if there's a bunch of people endorsing
it and sponsoring it then I'll say oh
yeah that's the program that has the
political will behind it and I wish all
of them well I still want to know I to
me the guarantee is important because I
want people to be able to switch around
switch life plans I want people to have
this independence the basic income gives
them because I think will bargain better
at work I think will build new
organizations new businesses things that
we actually want some of them may be
collectively owned I think we're gonna
take option
that are pretty exciting if we really
know we have the income if it takes
another step to get in there if I have
to convince someone I actually need the
money
hey I once to have this income now I
don't I'm worried we're gonna even if we
really would get it rumors get out when
I organize low income people so many
people believed that they're just not
gonna get something like food stamps
right even if they really would and they
all thought oh they're getting food
stamps but we're not so there's
something about these conditional
programs that lose trust and that's one
reason why for me the simplicity of the
dividend yeah citizens dividend is
another word for basic income another
reason why I like that is people are
actually gonna see it and they'll
actually know it exists no doubt Jason
Murphy we are going to continue
following developments in the world of
universal basic income and all of these
other ideas really appreciate you
talking to me about it again you were
ahead of a whole lot of folks when you
were covering this pretty early and I I
really appreciate that David